[Musique]
à Tours la brigade d'impulsion poétique
va m'offrir une parenthèse
chorégraphique et musicale anti
anti-morrosité la Madrugada offre à
travers quatre artistes musiciens et
danseurs des chorégraphies et des
moments poétiques aux habitants de Tours
le corps en mouvement c'est comme ça
qu'il crée afin de proposer au plus
grand nombre une position enfin une
proposition culturelle inédite dans des
positions surnaturelles mais fracasser
les gars
[Musique]
alors ça a commencé comment
ce concept on a en fait
le deuxième confinement et on s'est dit
que nous on avait envie de continuer à
bouger à penser aller à la rencontre des
gens et on s'est dit on va se réunir et
puis on va voir ce qu'on fait puis on
avait envie d'une brigade qui allait
jouer alors au départ notre idée c'était
d'aller sous les fenêtres des gens qui
pouvaient à l'époque pas sortir de chez
eux et donc on pouvait de proposer
quelque chose qui pouvait s'observer de
chez soi en fait
[Musique]
du coup toi tu es le musicien c'est
Mathieu ouais je joue de la musique mais
je danse aussi avec elle danse aussi
parce que toi tu es vraiment un
saxophoniste de formation
tout ça conservatoire la totale puis je
continue de me former mais plus dans de
la musique improvisée alors du coup la
danse tu as eu le temps de faire ça
quand la danse j'ai commencé à danse
avec Louisiane la prof
Louisane alors du coup tu es el
professeur on est où ici on est au 37e
parallèle c'est une grande structure qui
accueille plusieurs compagnies de
musique de théâtre et de danse
[Musique]
poésie on va parler poésie brigade
d'impulsion poétique comment on exprime
la poésie on peut l'exprimer de
plusieurs façons et nous notre médium
c'est la danse et la musique on aime
bien l'expression réenchanter le
quotidien réenchanter le réel c'est à
dire que on débarque sur une place et
puis on transforme le lieu on s'amuse
avec une fontaine on s'amuse avec un
trottoir on détourne les objets du
quotidien on donne une petite surprise
une petite bulle poétique au passant au
spectateur
[Musique]
en fait
ils sont partis bouffer à prévenir aussi
les gars